[Music]
hey everyone how's it going welcome back
to the channel today's episode is an
interview with someone I admire and
respect very much as an architect and as
a person if I had to use one word to
describe him it would be generous he is
generous in his word in his practice and
is just an incredibly generous and
wonderful person Scott Kim is a sole
practitioner who's been working with
indigenous communities for the past 15
years and before that he's worked with
architects like shin Takamatsu and big
Tom and before he started his own
practice he was a partner at Omicron but
he decided to follow his passion when he
started working with First Nations
communities I thought it would be
interesting to hear from him because
right now I feel like a lot of us are
learning and relearning how to engage
with our communities especially the ones
who's been marginalized throughout
history and as you know the indigenous
people of Canada have been chronically
mistreated throughout history and so we
will take a look at how he helps to
create positive change in these
communities through some of his projects
Scott also sits on a lot of local and
national committees including the Cala
the Canadian architectural licensing
authorities and the AI VC the
architectural Institution of Canada and
the AAF BC the architectural foundation
of Canada and he was also the past
president of the AIB scene right now it
seems that there is a push for change in
the profession and so I wanted to hear
his thoughts on our roles as architects
as well as his thoughts on the future of
the profession
you
yeah I just had a document from UBC
leaked to me from one of my friends and
they are requesting a lot of changes
within the program and one of them is
actually more diversity within the
faculty so right now if you have a more
academic experience or if you went to a
prestigious university than your
experiences it has higher value than
someone who has like 10 years of working
with communities or working in the field
and yeah I thought that was pretty
interesting it's a it's actually a
really nasty catch-22 is if you're
interested in teaching mm-hmm you almost
forced not to practice as any university
if you're working towards tenure you
have to do research practice isn't
considered research so you end up having
to do one or the other and I think
that's big problem I think you want more
not just obsessional teachers full-time
teachers but also practice yeah yeah
sure that is critical in the academia
you know if you have some academics
that's fine
they seem to really like the starter
tech that's their whole band I'm not
really sure why but I think there needs
to be a better balance you there's some
need or requirement or an academic view
on architecture but that needs to be
tempered with the practice needs to be
both and in an unbalanced one way or
another like I think most of our
universities are too academic
in the practice of architecture hmm and
I think that's it should swing back the
other way mmm yeah well that's what a
lot of like I'm a part of the young
architects conference and that's sort of
the common theme that like we want the
academics to be more grounded in reality
and this whole desire to do star tech
the kind of in reality very very few
buildings are such that it gives you
that opportunity
oh yeah like you're kind of designing
your path to for that one percent or
like zero point yeah they've trained all
the architects they will never have the
opportunity to do that you can't that
make sense
yeah yeah yeah that's kind of silly but
what do you want out of the profession
like that's the one beauty of both
architecture is so diverse there's so
many opportunities that you can find
your own path and so how long have you
been working with First Nation
communities well 15 years yeah okay so
what made you make that drastic shift
from you're a partner at Omicron right
well it's kind of what I mentioned
earlier you know what do you love to do
hmm
to do architecture yeah the actual
architect I'm not a businessman
in fact I'm the pub leave I would say a
really lousy businessman I thought a
market and managed firms yeah no website
no website I like doing it yeah me too
as communities are they come up with the
design I like doing the drawings that I
going on site swinging a hammer it's a
bit of a trap this profession so as you
get older and as you get into more
senior positions bad thing is you do
less and less architecture and I said
well that's nuts that's good so at that
point I said okay well I'm gonna start
my own firm it's going to be me people
work on contract with me avid gentleman
Michael that's working with me from day
one and he's great
so he's very good at doing drawings he's
very good at helping me mm-hmm F Kelly
there's another gentleman Brian another
young architect mm-hmm again there's no
firm for me to hand over there's no firm
for somebody to buy mmm what I'm trying
to do is help young people start so I'm
helping Kelly mmm it's not helping Ryan
so they can use my portfolio my work to
start their own friends that's a very
selfless approach to practicing
architecture you're you know creating
capacity at the firm level or I guess
not firm at the practice level and then
at the project level with the
communities creating capacity I am I
have very simple criteria I don't do a
project if I don't think it's gonna be
fun I'm enough and I could be selected
of enough mm-hmm
that's what I do if if it looks like
it's not gonna be fun I say you know I'd
love to do it but I'm just too busy what
do you want out of your career ask
yourself that now and then create a path
leading to that cuz don't work for 20
years and then think oh well what should
I do now but now you want your own firm
what kind of firm do you want what kind
of work do you want to do money do you
want make what kind of projects do you
want to do how do you want to do them
ask yourself those questions
and you will more likely get yourself
into position where you're enjoying
yourself what you want we tend to be too
project focused as architects we're
working on the project that we have at
the moment design your own career our
own project you need to do that if you
can name three skills that young
architects should develop what would it
be
um passion what you do okay and then you
need to develop all the tools so you
need to be able to listen to get the
kind of input needed and then you need
to be able to express that to draw it
will visualize do it in front of people
yeah that's we we run away in we design
it and then we come back and we say you
know don't you love it it is nice it is
I think that's wrong if you really want
to design for community you need to do
in front of them mm-hmm do it with them
you need to be inclusive right to share
the process with them hmm
don't hide behind your office and
Surprise them with it you don't want to
sell them again especially with
indigenous communities because they've
had things sold to them all the time
let's roll small record
to me the fun is actually working with
them working with them so develop your
passion develop your skills and learn to
just work with people listen listen
since the most important thing because
we don't often missing it
you're the presenters we stand up front
and present our projects we defend our
projects that's how we're trained to do
it we get critiqued we get to take
mm-hmm that's wrong
that's the wrong way to do architecture
especially community based architecture
sorry Connect for sure if you want to do
community based architecture it's them
beam and that's how the thing is you
need to inspire you are the team leader
right
you know you're seen as the kind of
visionary but that's human on-site you
need to inspire the workers you don't go
on site kind of is the arrogant
architect criticizing science yeah these
little soft skills are things that
you're expected to know but it's rarely
talked about or taught in schools again
the same is the hard stuff is easy and
it's easy stuff that's hard so that
we're trained to do architecture mm-hmm
that's easy stuff hard stuff is the
softest of inspiring people tuna tease
yeah so right now there's a big push
from the younger generation of
architects for change in the profession
especially in regards to diversity
and you sit on a lot of boards I want to
get your thoughts on what needs to
happen what do you think will happen in
the future in the future of the
profession certainly diversity is a you
know big issue and it's talked about a
lot nationally
again we tend to be still stereotyped as
the old white guys I think that's
changing I think it could change faster
like for instance yourself and people
like Kelly these are the young stars in
our profession most kind of
institutionalized entities and to have a
kind of momentum and weight to them and
it's hard to change directions it does
take time but I think the most influence
you can have is this individual you know
that's why it's at the time helping
Kelly get registered that's why I'm
spending time helping Kelly and Ryan
start their own firm but that transition
to your own firm is a huge issue like
it's right how can you get work how can
you how can you survive financially but
I know with what I've done over the last
few years I can help them I think to me
you can do you know the kind of changes
on a bigger scale happen slowly that you
can also make changes that have had a
more personal scale and since FIFA you
know game it was a little program that
we started in BC now it's Canada wide so
foreign trained architects again I think
that's hugely important effectively I'm
a trained architect I'm you know trained
in the UK when I moved back to Canada
they didn't recognize my qualifications
whatsoever so I had to do the whole
internship again oh really
the whole thing I got my degrees
certified by CCP I did the internship I
wrote all the incurved exams I did the
oral exam I did a whole thing to me that
was crazy
when when I was approached about setting
up beef I said yeah course yes that's
what it should be and we should be open
and recognize each other so we're
working we've signed quite a few m-ras
mutual recognition agreements so Canada
has a reciprocity with the states well
just signed four years ago I've used the
reciprocity with Australian New Zealand
we've signed reciprocity with Europe so
all 27 countries in Europe we as their
architects recognize architects in
Canada
again I think those are the broad steps
that you can make the profession
stronger should be open and inclusive if
the more diversity we have the stronger
we are we're a very small number in the
world like in Canada we have somewhere
around 10,000 architects I think there's
many hundreds of thousands of lawyers in
Canada you know 10,000 isn't very much
um but if we work collectively this is
much louder than and I think when you
start working it's kind of hard to find
the time to be involved in other things
outside of your project you seem like
you you seem like the kind of person who
genuinely enjoys all these
extracurricular activities yeah the game
I work with very nice people but we're
doing good work that benefits the
profession so you can't ask for any more
and Ellen so is like we always want
younger practitioners and part of the
challenges is prioritizing so when
you're young and you careers say for
yourself
the next day five years like if you want
your own firm you have to focus on that
so how much time do you have
doing like volunteer at the IBC
voluntary national more towards the end
of your career when your firm's more
established it seems that's when people
get involved in those sort of activities
I think the air of everything right now
it's a lot of young people are getting
mobilized and really they want to be a
more active member of the profession so
I think in the next few years we will
see a lot more younger people
in these committees which is good again
the NBC isn't this you know abstract
entity it's you ABC is the richest
architects of BC are the members we
govern we control it the ABC has staff
staffs under the direction of counsel so
you want to change what the ABC is doing
then mechanism do it lower the fees
again that's an interesting one you got
a lot of people will say that cuz like
in the state's you know I can range from
Washington cuts under bucks but then
they're not self-regulating is regulated
by the government we are truly
self-regulating and as far as I know
we're the last country in the world or
architecture truly self-regulating
authority that we have govern the
profession is then hold back in almost
every other country that I know we have
full authority to do it so that's
fantastic what that means we need to
fund it that's your membership what are
some of the tangible benefits of being
self-regulating we set up beefin I'm
gonna have no say in that we did it we
signed the m-ras
we didn't commit has no say in it right
is that decision so if the government
was involved it would be a much longer
process yeah there's like we sign
Australia New Zealand through what's
called APEC you know there's that it's
the asia-pacific economic corporation or
something form so there's a trade deal
APEC and the with a lot of the countries
we met we suggested to them candidate it
let's do an MRI so we recognized each
other almost everyone said what we don't
have disorder to do we can't do it Oh
interesting
evan has to do it Australia New Zealand
are similar to us they don't have as
much authority as we do the big issue so
we could able we were able to negotiate
with them on Kong Philippines Singapore
Malaysia they all said we can't do it
the government controls that Oh
interesting
and even Europe there's what they call
ace Architects Council of Europe mmm
and that's who we negotiated with and
signed the MRA with but they have to go
back each of their entities and none of
them have the authority that we have we
just decide we don't need the
government's approval to do this we have
the government support come and actually
likes us doing this but we have the
authority to do it
[Music]